foreign
it's such a privilege to be here
being home secretary is not just a
tremendous honor
keeping the British people safe and
securing our borders are the highest
duties of State
our prime minister understands those
duties
and so do I
we stand for the law-abiding majority of
britons
and in doing so
I draw on a long tradition of
conservative home secretaries who are
willing to challenge failing Orthodoxy
they refuse to accept defeat
Michael Howard on his first day as Home
Secretary was told that there was
nothing that he could do about the
inevitable rise of crime
he disagreed and crime fell dramatically
they said that Theresa May couldn't
Deport Abba Qatar the islamist extremist
but and despite setbacks along the way
she made it happen
pretty Patel negotiated a groundbreaking
deal with our partners in Rwanda to
bring forward a new solution for the
challenge of illegal migration providing
protection in Rwanda for those that need
it whilst breaking the business models
uh the business model of people
Smugglers
I'm grateful to pretty and Boris for the
foundations that they laid
serious violent crime Has Fallen
as has overall crime excluding fraud and
online theft and we are well on the way
to 20 000 additional police officers
but a Home Secretary can never be a
complacent and some things still need
fixing
I'm pleased to be working with a
brilliant team of ministers who I'm so
pleased to see with us today Tom
tugenhart Tom persglove Jeremy Quinn
Mims Davies and Lord Andrew sharp
supported by our excellent pps's Gareth
Davies and Sean Bailey they all bring
talent and expertise to the home office
now the Prime Minister and I want to see
homicide serious violence and
neighborhood crime Fall by 20 percent
some of our most committed and
courageous people serve in the police
in Belfast
in Belfast last week I joined police
leaders to pay tribute
to those officers who have died in
action
their ultimate sacrifice is one for it
for which we owe a huge debt of
gratitude
foreign
so yes I'm immensely proud of our police
now many on the left they want to defund
the police
well I say to the militants I say to the
anarchists and the extremists no I will
always back our police men and women
that's what being on the side of the law
abiding majority means
but we also need to be frank when things
go wrong
some police officers have fallen
devastatingly short of the standards
expected
we need to get back to Common Sense
policing empowering the police to tackle
the issues facing the public not
policing pronouns on Twitter or
non-crime
thank you
are not policing non-crime hate
incidents that's why I'm very pleased to
see that greater Manchester police
Hampshire bedfordshire northamptonshire
and the Metropolitan Police have all
promised now to visit the scene of every
burglary
but the law-abiding majority
respect every Force to investigate every
neighborhood crime and so do I drugs car
theft vandalism and anti-social Behavior
cannot be ignored
foreign
the most unsettling and unspeakable
crime of all is rape
now as an MP and as the Attorney General
I've already seen firsthand how the
system needs to do better
I can't change things overnight but I
will not accept the status quo
now policing is a public service and
must be accountable to you the public
that's why it's right that we publish
League tables that show how well every
force in England and Wales is doing in
their fight against Crime you all have
the right to know and greater
transparency will drive up standards
now the modern world inevitably brings
new challenges
our national security bill will ensure
that law enforcement and intelligence
agencies have the tools that they need
to stay ahead of the country's ever more
sophisticated adversaries
yet everything starts from getting the
basics right we need Common Sense
policing unashamedly unapologetically on
the side of the law abiding majority
and that means that the mob needs to be
stopped
the police
the police must have all the powers that
they need to stop the protesters who use
Guerrilla tactics and bring chaos and
misery to the law-abiding majority
thank you
it's not a human right to vandalize
property
it's not my freedom of expression to
protest violently no you can't just
start a riot or glue yourself to the
roads and get away with it
yes friends as attorney general I had to
go to court to get some of these simple
truths established the judges agreed
with me last week in the court of appeal
in the Colston statue case and that's
why our public order bill will Empower
our police to stop this nuisance so
whether you're just stop oil or insulate
Britain or Extinction Rebellion you
cross a line when you break the law and
that's why we'll keep putting you behind
bars
thank you
now it's very easy to say that the
culture wars are a distraction
but make no mistake the left
are attacking our profound Elemental
values
wanting to replace them with the poison
of identity politics
foreign
seeps into the public sphere it
distracts our public servants from doing
their real job
a philosophy dominates the labor party
whatever
ever securma pretends
and that's why
for the police to take the knee it is
wrong for them to join in with political
demonstrations it is wrong for
biologically male police officers to
strip search female suspects
and it's not just that pandering to
Identity politics is a huge waste of
time they need to stick to catching the
bad guys
now those who
dismiss political correctness as a
conservative obsession
I say this
I say visit Rochdale
visit Telford
The Grooming gang Scandal is a stain on
this country and it's what happens when
political correctness becomes more
important than criminal justice more PCS
less PC
now my other mission is to control our
borders
firstly legal migration now I backed
brexit because I wanted Britain to have
control over my our migration and to cut
overall numbers brexit was meant to give
us a say on how we determine our own
migration policy
we should use our Newfound control to
deliver the kind of migration that grows
our economy for example that helps
projects that have stalled or built
friendships and relationships with our
allies
but the truth is parts of our system
aren't delivering
we need to end the abuse of the rules
and we need to cut down on those numbers
that aren't meeting the needs of our
economy
and we mustn't forget how to do things
for ourselves
there is absolutely no reason why we
can't train up enough of our own hgv
drivers or butchers or fruit Pickers
the way we build a high skilled
high-wage economy is by encouraging
business to invest in capital and
domestic labor not relying wholly on
low-skilled foreign workers
foreign
now this just isn't just about policy or
economics for me it's intensely personal
my parents came to this country in the
1960s from Kenya and Mauritius
they loved Britain from afar as children
of the Commonwealth
it was Britain that offered them
security and opportunity as young adults
I'm not embarrassed to say that I love
Britain
no conservative is
not racist for anyone ethnic minority or
otherwise to want to control our borders
it's not bigoted to say that we have too
many Asylum Seekers who are abusing the
system
it's not xenophobic to say that mass and
Rapid migration places pressure on
housing public services and community
relations
I reject the left's argument that it is
hypocritical for someone from an ethnic
minority to tell these truths
my parents came here through legal and
controlled migration they spoke the
language they threw themselves into the
community they embraced British values
when they arrived they signed up to be
part of our shared project because the
United Kingdom meant something distinct
integration was part of the quid pro quo
now that didn't mean abandoning their
Heritage but it did me adopting British
identity an ident identity of which we
should all be proud
is the best place on Earth to come and
live in but I fear
I fear that we are losing sight of the
core values and the culture that made it
so
the unexamined drive towards
multiculturalism as an end in itself
combined with the corrosive aspects of
identity politics has led us astray
I saw this when I went to Leicester
recently
a Melting Pot of cultures and a beacon
of religious Harmony but but even there
riots and civil disorder have taken
place because of failures to integrate
large numbers of newcomers
such conflict has no place in the UK
or when we look at the prevent scheme we
see how cultural tensions within
communities are not being handled well
enough
the murderer
of our much list dear friend sir David
Amos
had been referred to prevent
but it couldn't stop him
we cannot as a people be cowed into fear
by vocal minorities who attempt to
undermine our Common Sense instincts and
as Home Secretary I will make sure that
prevent is fit for purpose the law
abiding majority deserve nothing less
foreign
we've got to stop the boats crossing the
channel
this has gone on
for far too long
but I have to be straight with you there
are no quick fixes and the problem is
chronic
organized criminal gangs are selling a
lie to thousands of people
many are drowning in the channel
many are leaving a safe country like
France and abusing our Asylum system
so what's our plan
firstly our work with the French has
prevented about half of all the
crossings now I know that that alone
will not work
so I will work closely with the French
to get more out of our partnership both
on the French Coastline and further
Upstream against the organized criminal
gangs
secondly we need to find a way to make
the Rwanda scheme work
thirdly we need to do more to get Asylum
Seekers out of hotels currently costing
the British taxpayer five million pounds
a day
and fourth we cannot allow a foreign
Court to undermine the sovereignty of
our borders
for a few months ago the European Court
of human rights in Strasbourg did just
that
by a closed process with an unnamed
judge and without any representation by
the UK a European Court overrode our
Supreme Court
and as a result our first flight to
Rwanda was grounded
we need to take back control
but friends I need to be honest with you
Strasbourg court is not the only problem
now everyone agrees
that we must fight the evil of modern
slavery
I'm immensely proud of this country's
Global Leadership
in protecting genuine victims
but the hard truth
is that our modern slavery laws are
being abused by people gaining the
system we've seen a 450 percent increase
in modern slavery claims since 2014.
today
the largest group of small boats
migrants
are from Albania safe country
many of them claim to be trafficked as
modern slaves
that's despite them having paid
thousands of pounds to come here or
having willingly taken a dangerous
Journey on the channel
the truth is that many of many of them
are not modern slaves and their claims
of being trafficked are lies
and it's not just illegal migrants
since entering the home office I have
seen egregious examples
of convicted pedophiles and rapists
trying to gain the system
making last-minute claims of modern
slavery to block their removal from the
country
some have even gone on to commit further
crimes in the interim
in one case
a convicted sex offender from South
Africa had spent a year in prison
he was about to be deported from the
United Kingdom and lo and behold he made
a claim of modern slavery
our removal was stalled and in this time
he went on to commit a further rape
he's now behind bars
but when he's released well it's also
terribly predictable
in another case a pedophile from
Pakistan
received 10 years in prison
but at the end of his prison sentence he
put in a spurious claim
to be a modern slave
and even when he got through that
process
he made a second claim which blocked his
removal we simply cannot go on like this
we need to make sure that our system
strikes the right balance
our laws need to be resilient against
abuse whilst it's at the same time
ensuring that we help those in genuine
need
we've got a proud history of offering
Sanctuary to those in need from
supporting the thousands of bnos fleeing
persecution in Hong Kong to welcoming
nearly 20 000 Afghan Nationals fleeing
war and Terror to offering immediate
Refuge to thousands of ukrainians
fleeing Putin's barbarism the UK and
this conservative government has always
been there to hold out the Hand of Hope
to Mo to those who need it most
foreign
it isn't working in the interests of the
British people or people who need our
help the most
our laws are being abused
abused by people Smugglers and criminals
peddling false promises
abused by people making multiple
meritless and last minute claims
abused by tactics from Specialists small
boat chasing law firms
this cannot continue
so conference I will commit to you today
that I will look to bring forward
legislation to make it clear that the
only route to the United Kingdom is
through a safe and legal route
so that we can help support those who
need our help the most including women
and girls so if you deliberately enter
the United Kingdom illegally from a safe
country you should be swiftly returned
to your home country or relocated to
Rwanda
that is where your Asylum claim will be
considered
UK policy on illegal migration should
not be derailed by abuse of our modern
slavery laws Labor's Human Rights Act or
orders of the Strasbourg Court
and we will always
of course work within the bounds of
international law but we cannot allow
this abuse of our system to continue
and of course at the same time we need
to Stamp Out illegal working practices
we already have some of the toughest
penalties for those not playing by our
rules but we will redouble our efforts
to go after them
but I need to be straight with you
conference
this will not be easy
I cannot promise you a solution
immediately
we've all heard pledges and promises but
this problem is complex and entrenched
and there are many forces working
against us
the labor party will try to stop this
the lib Dem will go bananas
The Guardian guardian will have a
meltdown yeah
as for the lawyers don't get me started
on the lawyers and I'm a recovery lawyer
[Applause]
for what I can
what I can pledge to you is my total
and undeniable and unfettered and
unconditional commitment to doing
whatever it takes and despite those
obstacles I won't give up on you and I
won't give up on the British people
thank you
it's very kind that I hadn't actually
finished
my goodness now if I don't get a
standing evasion at the end what do I
make of that
ladies and gentlemen friends conference
the time for words is over
now is the time for action it's time to
put the will of the hard-working
patriotic majority at the heart of all
we do it's time for the police to stop
to stop virtue signaling and start start
catching robbers and burglars it's time
to tackle the small boats no ifs no buts
friends it's time for common sense I
stand ready to serve you I stand ready
to deliver the time is ours the time is
now thank you conference